so after getting a very late start the
english finally started a new world
colony on the coast of north america
in 1607 and it was here at jamestown
the english colonists at jamestown could
not have been less prepared to settle a
new world they came from the virginia
company
which was a joint stock company
or kind of like a modern-day corporation
which was trying to make wealth for its
shareholders as quickly as possible now
if you think about people in this time
period they in england are taking a look
over at spain and seeing spain bring
ships full of gold and silver back to
europe from the new world and they want
to get in on that action and as far as
they know the whole new world is just
piled up with silver and gold so in the
first months they sent gentlemen
and the english definition of a
gentleman here is someone who does not
work with his hands
to try to find gold
in virginia now spoiler alert there is
no gold in virginia but that whole first
summer when they were there they could
have been planting crops they could have
been fishing i mean this is actually a
pretty
bountiful area when it comes to natural
resources in plants and animals but they
were trying to find gold they were
trying to basically get rich quick this
was the scheme but then winter rolled
around those who hadn't already been
killed by mosquito-borne illnesses like
malaria or yellow fever were now subject
to starvation
and there the story gets even more
complicated because the english settlers
who were all men by the way they were
adventurers they were not there to start
families start a long-term colony in the
new world they just wanted to find gold
and get out so as these english
colonists are starving they start to run
afoul of local native americans they
were an algonquian tribe living in the
virginia tidewater who were under
the rule of this man here
and this is a drawing of him done by
john smith who we'll talk about in a
second his name was powhatan his real
name was wahun sunika but the english
called him powhatan and the people that
he ruled the powhatans
and as the english settlers realized
that they had not put it away enough for
practically any stores to get them
through the winter they started raiding
the food supplies
of the powhatans which of course didn't
make them very happy they were also
trying to survive the winter and the
powhatans kidnapped john smith
there's an engraving of him here
and they kind of tried to
show him their power so there's a legend
that powhatan was intending to execute
john smith the daughter of powhatan
pocahontas also wasn't her real name
that was her nickname it kind of meant
little playful person
her real name was mata aka
but we know her today by her nickname
pocahontas and pocahontas intervened and
kept her father from executing john
smith either out of the goodness of her
heart or maybe because she had a crush
on him this is pretty much completely
untrue the disney version of this story
says that pocahontas and john smith go
on to fall in love and get married the
fact of the matter was that pocahontas
was probably about
13 years old
at the time
and she will go on to marry an
englishman but not john smith john rolfe
who is famous in another way which we'll
get to soon it's also quite likely that
powhatan didn't actually intend to
execute smith instead what he was doing
was kind of a a ritual of power
and mercy
so he's doing kind of a mock execution
saying all right i have the power to
execute you but then pocahontas playing
her ritual role steps in to say no have
mercy so he says you know i could kill
you but because i'm a strong leader but
because i am also a merciful and just
leader i will not so after his
kidnapping john smith really kind of
steps up as the savior of jamestown
which probably
would have completely collapsed worry
not for him and in 1608 he takes over
and says that he who shall not work
shall not eat so you gotta pull your
weight
if you're gonna get supported
by the rest of the colonists
nevertheless the first years at
jamestown were pretty rough in the
winter of 1609 to 1610 which they called
the starving time
the colonists were so hungry that
they resorted to eating vermin
and
they resorted to eating each other one
man actually killed and ate his wife in
one of the few known examples of english
cannibalism so jamestown was a pretty
rough place to be only about 15 percent
of the settlers who went to jamestown
actually survived in fact that following
spring of 1610 they decided to give up
and head back to england they were met
just as they were leaving by new supply
ships
that continued
the virginia experiment which will
become much more successful after the
discovery of tobacco
we'll get to that in the next video